[Music]
welcome back to follow the money Iran
announced its military would practice
closing the straight of Hormuz one of
the world's most vital oil shipping
lanes this just days after they showed
off one of our drones that they claim
they forced out of the sky so is war
with Iran becoming a possibility join me
now Robert Spencer of watch Mr Spencer
thank you so much I I want to get to the
Drone in just a minute but please talk
to our viewers about how important the
straight of hormos is and then why in
the world would anyone let them do
military uh procedures practices in in
that very important shipping Lane well
yes Eric as you say it's crucially
important for the uh oil shipping
industry and so it could completely
strangulate the American economy where
it closed for any uh indefinite period
and uh closing it would ESS be an active
war that would be why the Iranians would
close it uh we have to remember that
Iran has considered itself to be in a
state of War uh essentially in in in any
effective way uh with the United States
since 1979 and so uh they want war with
Israel there are these genocidal
statements that
mad and the uh other the mullah have
made in Iran about destroying Israel and
even bringing about the end of the
United States and so the closing of the
straights of mov would all be in line
with that overarching agenda okay and
and again they they did try to actually
they it closed it briefly if I'm not
mistaken in what in the late 70s when
they put some uh some mines in the water
there but then it was swept and we got
we got it clear but so they're not
they're not afraid of actually pulling
this off are they oh no certainly not
and why should they be afraid now with
Barack Obama as President and everything
they do he just comes back with more
obsequious attempts to outre reach and
uh more concessions now he's even
against sanctions when a couple years
ago he was saying no we're going to have
strong sanctions and uh the sanctions
are the only thing that he's done uh
there are a couple of nuclear reactors
that have exploded in Iran and we can
all be grateful for that since the even
the iaea and Hillary Clinton have
acknowledged that Iranian nuclear
program is oriented toward making
nuclear weapons and yet the US has not
played a role in that that seems to have
been an Israeli operation and the once
again we owe Israel as when they took
out the osak reactor in the 80s once
again we owe Israel a uh a great debt of
gratitude so what's not to be afraid of
when Mr Obama makes statements like this
when they shot when they took down our
drone here's Obama's response to us
losing a very very important piece of
technology take a listen we have asked
for it
back we'll see how the Iranians
respond sir you know the problem is I
think I figured it out Obama forgot to
say pretty please
yes but maybe if he if he puts together
an aid package of a few billion maybe
they'll uh loosen up but meanwhile the
uh it appears that the Russians have
given technology to Iran to be able to
track and to shoot down these drones now
they have the Drone if they do give it
back it will only be after they have
copied all the technology in it and they
know how it works so they can replicate
it and so uh Obama he asks for it back I
mean even Jimmy Carter tried to mount a
raid to get the hostages out sure and
and we need to point out you know it's
not just us you know throwing flame
Throwing Fire on an already burning fire
Mitt Romney today on the news channel
said he would have gone in and gotten
that drone back one way or another or
destroyed it so it's not out of the
realm to say hey we could have done more
than what we did other than just let him
have the Drone and ask we're pretty
pleased can we have it back Mr oini J of
course without any doubt I mean see this
comes from Obama's refusal to recognize
that Iran does act as if it's at war
with the United States and we need to
deal with it accordingly but instead he
keeps pretending that if he makes nice
enough then the mulas will be nice back
and yet again and again and again he's
proven wrong right all right that's
Robert Spencer from Jihad watch thank
you so much for joining us sir always a
pleasure Eric thank you